so there's still one more feature that
you could add to your project to round
out functionality for registering for a
conference once you've registered you
can't actually unregister so even though
the UI shows us the unregister button
users can't actually click it to
unregister because you haven't written
the functionality to unregister the user
from a conference it's up to you if
you'd like to go ahead and implement the
unregister functionality feel free to
add the function unregister from
conference and put it in conference API
if you'd like I'm going to leave you to
do this on your own if you want to
couple things old I do need to point out
is that the UI is expecting the function
to be called unregister from conference
and it is expecting it to throw these
exceptions one other thing here is that
we have an at named web safe conference
key so this function knows to expect the
web safe conference key to be passed to
the function and if you go to the api's
Explorer you'll see that it offers the
web safe conference key field for you to
enter the value if you want anyway it's
up to you if you'd like to go ahead and
implement this function but it does tie
together a lot of the concepts that
you've learned such as using
transactions and getting an entity by
key and changing property values